[Music]
did Steve Bannon betray president Trump
the president wouldn't answer that
question at the White House earlier but
he did offer these words about his
former aide now persona non grata
I don't really call me a great man last
night so he obviously changed his tune
pretty quick thank you all very much
despite yesterday's public lashing from
his former boss Bannon had only nice
words to say about mr. Trump last night
the president I states is a great man
you know I support him day in and day
out whether going through the country
given the Trump miracle speech or on the
show on the website so I don't think you
have to worry about that but I
appreciate the kind words the chief
strategist now faces the threat of legal
action from the president's lawyers over
quote disparaging statements and
violating an agreement not to disclose
confidential information he's been sent
a cease and desist letter to avoid any
further disclosures so has author
Michael Wolfe who published bannon's
quotes in a new book about the Trump
White House the president is trying to
stop the book from being released but
it's now due out tomorrow for days early
so Vermont I thought I would start with
you on the legal front or if Kimberly
view take it either way but at this
point the book is coming out I mean
there's really nothing you can do
legally right well like you could do a
cease and desist letter I am opposed to
them they show kind of a panic they
bring more attention than you know they
are ineffective there's a First
Amendment in this country they have the
right to publish and then be sued you
know it's obvious that they're friendly
above plenty of problems with the book
as seen through the the eyes of the
Trump administration but they're trying
to stop at ahead of time does nothing
other than to drive sales and it looks
frightened Charles Harbor the attorney
that they have Hart a hired is the is a
real formidable attorney he's the guy
that crushed gawker.com you know on
behalf of Hulk Hogan you remember so I
think that you know that's real but why
draw even more attention it's it's
really look at this fire you know it's
it's the kind of thing you don't
you don't want to do and well it's done
is accelerate the publications yeah I
think Emily I was saying earlier today
that when you are dealing with a book PR
situation if it's negative for your
principal there's there's two ways to
deal with that either try to ignore it
and starve it of attention or try to
counter punch and the president
statements was really strong yesterday
and then Sarah Sanders had this to say
earlier that's not seriously I'm not
going to waste my time or the country's
time going page by page talking about a
book that's complete fantasy and just
full of tabloid gossip cuz it's sad
pathetic there are probably more than
thirty requests for access to
information from Michael Wolfe that were
repeatedly denied he never discussed
this book with the president it was
repeatedly denied that I think because
we saw him for what he was and there was
no reason for us to waste the President
of the United States time Sarah Sanders
Kimberly is having to clean up a mess
that she didn't start which is inviting
Michael wolf into the White House in the
first place yes well I mean it's a
problem but I don't look they decided
somehow some way that they were gonna
give him access and he has had access to
very high-profile people like chairman
and you know donor of this company and
former chairman so he's actually had the
ability to get these kind of interviews
and get unfettered access I think you
know early on in an administration
anyway probably not a very good idea
it's an ill-advised because you're not
gonna let somebody being exposed to the
shop the first day it opens like
restaurants they open up it's like a lot
of things going on yeah yeah I rates a
little like baked in event and you've
got a few Zagat reviews but besides that
so then you let a minute and he's like
hey
so he's like listening right he's paying
attention to everything quite
conversational he's talking to everyone
and what you think he may hear or not
hear you know he's picking up more than
you think you saw that by some of the
Sean Spicer stuff where he's listening
and absorbing the environment that's
what he does so in a situation like this
it's vulnerable for a presidency for an
administration to put themselves you
know at risk
I'm for us for someone like this that is
obviously gonna you know that it's a
good writer that's going to write all
this stuff out and obviously there's a
lot of you know
tension in terms of the accuracy of it
but he says the s tapes as well the
publishers doubling devil let's be
honest they're trying to sell books so
because of all the you know the hype all
of the news coverage that you've seen on
absolutely every Network about this they
want to capitalize it in a free market
society be able to get the sales out
yeah that's the other thing Gregg is
that the the PR nightmare that that a
White House might be going through on
this it will end it'll be like two or
three more news two or three more days
of a new cycle probably go through the
sunday shows and then I think they'll be
on to another topic yeah but that's the
beauty of the trump presidency there's
always something coming over the horizon
blows your mind you go this is the end
of the world no hold my beer as people
like this don't make a tweet I have to
agree with Kimberly 100% on everything
she said so it's news it's chaos and
dysfunctional when non politicians
actually move into a political realm
isn't that what this is all about this
guy is there witnessing the end cronies
out and essentially you in these are
people that have not governed who are
just like the people who kind of vote
you could say yeah he's a billionaire
but he's kind of like your uncle so your
uncle just became president I challenge
that each one of us if we became
president would have had a similar maybe
except for Danny because she'd been
there before but we would have had a
similar experience and so I think the
books message before I was I'm what you
made a good point about the right or to
this is not about a perfect White House
it's about a human White House these are
not beautiful people from Davos or Aspen
or Harvard these are people who can
barely shave banning shaves half his
face these are people ignorant of
politics but savvy of the street you put
street fighters in there from Queens and
elsewhere and the Democrats have to be
consistent about this because they
nominated a neophyte over Hillary
Clinton remember they did it first with
Obama and they won so this this was just
the pendulum
lastly you said that wolf is a good
writer he is a good writer the reporting
is
strange to me in that it feels like is
forcing observations and conclusions to
fulfill the good story writing that he
made he has a great story he writes in
an active voice but the reporting is in
the passive it's as almost things are
happening without a reason
and I think that's weird so part of me
says yeah a lot of this could happen but
it's like he's shoveling it into a way
that it's a study that fits a story of
the New York Times said it was a thin
read well-written but could have used a
copy edit yeah you know with that is
though that's right intense rivalry
that's earth going right I wish I had
maybe came into the White House they
also say Trump didn't know Boehner and
then they came out with pictures of
Trump playing golf with Boehner so you
don't know what to believe but the
bottom line is that beddin betrayed the
family what's the quote from the
Godfather never go against the family
he went after Jared anyway but he'd been
leaking this was a direct way I don't
know if he was on the record is pretty
strongly as yes when he was at in
Alabama for the Roy Moore event on stage
on live television he was talking it was
basically making fun of Ivana Ivanka for
saying that the there's a special place
in hell for people like that are accused
of things that from day one there was
this was not any kind of kumbaya love
situation which we've Steve Bannon
between Ivanka Jared daun jr.
Jericho and maybe none of these rivals
concept then that could work for a
president well I think it's more like
Dallas this whole notion though where
they make an observation as damning as
the fact that they want to invoke the
25th amendment that the president is
having these memory and emotional lapses
and he's not himself this is such bump
I'm sorry to say but this this is
quoting people who spend no time with
the president you know I didn't spend
any time with him over the Christmas
holidays but we were together for an
hour cutting back on Air Force One from
Puerto Rico it was just the two of us
say we were rappin I've known him for 40
years we did the Celebrity Apprentice
together specifically six weeks together
every day he's as sharp as ever he is as
relaxed as ever in terms of his physical
prowess he can outrun me easily and I
think that too damn him in in that way
with it with the charge that is that
vague yeah and and yet that incendiary I
think it's very very unfair all the say
get out run you I mean you should very
hard-working he campaigned as hard as
anybody to ran for the office of
presidency he had no lack of any kind of
like fatigue in the situation he was a
hundred percent all in trying to win and
get after it
way more than Hillary Clinton let's be
honest she was happy to collect dollars
and he was out there trying to collect
votes okay making all the stops when it
was 1:00 in the morning he would show up
there like Michigan and make sure that
he made all those rallies and he talked
to every reporter every time we were at
one of those conventions or debates etc
he was out there the whole time doing
the press gaggle talking to everybody
and so if they try and take that away
from there just you know say what you
want about maybe something's might be
accurate criticism but don't go and
misrepresent and lie about the man's
like ability and his stamina you know
getting stuff that he wanted to wish
there isn't a day in his life that he
doesn't wake up and say I want to crush
it
I want to make the other guy cry for his
mom and me too that's all well you know
what the thing is some of these things
could be true I mean he could eat
cheeseburgers in bed I mean that's a
problem who doesn't who doesn't I mean
that would that's how I want to go
America but but he's not in your own
back yeah but if you if you look let's
say you look at some of the things and
you think some of these could be true
temperamental impulsive what whatever
you think I want to quote this guy is a
philosopher GAD sad he said if a
candidate or a person connects with you
on one big thing one big thing then all
the little things become little and they
become acceptable and I it was something
with me I had a lot of problems with a
lot of things especially make me mainly
about behavior and things that we've
talked about the five but the big thing
which was the message over national
domestic security the fact that he
nailed that down and has since followed
through with that makes me accept the
fact that yeah he might say something
that kind of like us oh I can't believe
he said that but the fact is if you get
the big thing right the little things
doesn't matter don't matter give credit
for the accomplishments and what's
actually right but people don't want to
talk about them they want to talk about
well is there you know does eat a
cheeseburger I mean god I hope so I mean
cheeseburgers obviously do amazing
things for your body